please welcome sabrina carpenter
this is very surreal
it is such an honor to have your
presence here on the show
you started at nine years old
yeah so how did you
know yourself well enough at nine to be
in touch with what you could do
i don't think i knew anything i think at
nine years old you just love what you
love and you just gravitate towards what
you gravitate towards like um i think
for me like i remember watching the
wizard of oz specifically like that was
a very vivid memory watching judy
garland sing when i was um like just
before i was nine and i was just in awe
and i was like oh i want to do that
forever if i can because if you started
singing at nine and putting yourself out
there was there an earlier year was
there a moment in your life where you're
where you had the i want to do this
moment yeah well i specifically remember
um there was a restaurant i went to when
i was six years old and there was a
waitress there patty and it was her
birthday and i was like oh i want to
sing happy birthday for you and so i
sang her happy birthday and then every
time i came back to that restaurant she
made me sing happy birthday to anyone in
the restaurant who had a birthday which
some people started to like give me
money and i was like oh i was like is
this my career and i was sick so i
didn't really know what i was saying my
parents were like you can't take that
and i was like are you sure i was like
because this is my business i mean i'm
so glad thank you i was like i wanted to
know a moment i love that so much
you have an amazing taste in music oh
thank you i mean who are some of your
favorites and inspirations
so many i think uh one of the first
songs my mom ever played me was eda
james at last and uh patsy cline crazy
um
dolly parton
don't get me started on dolly dolly's
like yeah dolly is my favorite like to
this day i love i love her so much i
love carly simon i love joni mitchell oh
yeah i mean who how did you find you
have amazing taste in music
how did you find it i think throughout
the years honestly if anything i feel
like i've really come back to like
artists like you know joanie and carol
kang and um you know marvin gaye like
there's there's so many incredible
artists that i just i really gravitate
towards the way it makes you feel and
the instrumentation of their songs just
kind of makes me feel like
elevated and
alive so i don't know i guess just like
through
searching you know um
you are always in songwriting mode and
you're very prolific
and you attack it in the moment one of
the reasons i fell in love with this
story about you is
it felt like
inspiration not lost how
do you remain in constant songwriting
mode how do you capture it what is that
life
um it's it's interesting because it's
i'm a little paranoid because i am
always
really listening to the things that
people are saying sometimes maybe too in
depth like on social media or live and
in person oh i would say more live and
in person social media you know scary um
i think live and in person you really
get this unfiltered version of
conversations and things that people
aren't necessarily like calculating
before they say so like you'll have
really really honest thoughts and
sometimes things that you go oh i can
never say that to a real person or i
could never put that in a song and i
think that's been like the main
inspiration for me is like what are
those moments that we feel like we
shouldn't say or we can't say um and
those are usually the best songs
[Music]